the Joe Rogan experience I think you're
so right and to make it like a not a
partisan thing our politics are so
shallow hollow Theatre cable news base
they're like Twitter politics and you
can see it not just with Trump who's
like the ultimate incarnation of that
but during this pandemic Andrew Cuomo is
like the celebrity governor Democrats
are like we gotta get him in there he's
amazing he's doing
New York had the worst outbreak of any
state and that's not all on him but it
is partly on him how was it let me tell
you a couple things yes in part yes but
also they shut down later right then
other places like Washington like
California which had a much lower
outbreak he mandated that nursing homes
take back in 43 percent of coronavirus
deaths are nursing homes this is a
nursing home panic mandated that they
take back in recovering kovat patients
and he happens that he got a you know
million dollar plus campaign check for
his re-election through affiliated
committee before he got reelected and so
he also put made sure to put into place
a liability for all their executives so
if they don't do a good job that can't
be held liable and that data shows is
correlated with increased kovat death
and infection rates because they know
that they're not gonna be held
responsible so there's a lower threshold
there so there were very specific
decisions that were really bad and
fueled the worst outbreak in the entire
country but because you can get on TV
and give a command and press conference
that's all people really care about he's
got like 80% approval ratings yeah has
he spoken about the recovering kovat
patients being readmitted to the nursing
homes not much because his brothers on
CNN is prime time anchor Chris Cuomo and
they do these ridiculous interviews
where they like joke around about how
big his nose is rather than asking
questions like that and look it'd be one
thing if you were gonna have your
brother on once or twice on time you
know but no night after night after
night it's the show of the two brothers
chumming it up while people are dying
this is a politician who's supposed to
be held to account
that is the police to be rolling around
with his brother joking about the size
of their nose in the swab well there are
like literally thousands of elderly
people who died because explicitly
because of this decision now we're not
saying nuweiba the decision but like
there needs to be some like scrutiny and
accountability of that nobody at CNN
wants to touch it because Chris Guam was
the anchor nobody at MSNBC wants to
touch it because he's the biggest
Democrat and they all live in New York
and I'll probably have dinner with each
other and of course I mean people on the
right are talking about it because he's
a Democrat yeah there's no I mean
outside Bristol and a few others on the
left you all right and on the right
they're total hypocrites to Fox News
picks it up with this like liability
story and how he gets this through
meanwhile Mitch McConnell's proposing
the same thing at a national level and
they're like a ok with that so I mean
this gets back to the sort of central
concept of the show we just hope we
don't do that shape you know like you
[ __ ] up on this thing like let's talk
about it if it's a Republican we're
gonna do the same thing and that's the
way I mean on a basic level that's
always supposed to be and it it's a big
big problem again going back to this
moment that we're living in because no
one trusts anyone for good reason even
if you are an MSNBC watcher and you know
it and you love it and you love Rachel
Maddow and whatever you know you're
getting spun you know that they're
taking certain stories that are gonna
like pique your interest and they're
ignoring everything but the end of every
the lesson of every single news story
cannot be ergo Trump is bad like that
cannot be the conclusion of literally
every news story and over on Fox News
the end conclusion of every news story
cannot be Ergo Democrats are evil and
unamerican right every week we all know
this know people are not that stupid
[Applause]